this yarn might not make the best
sweater but when pulled it generates
electricity an international team of
researchers have developed a technology
they referred to as twister on
harvesters these tiny twists consist of
a carbon nanotube string tied into a
tangled weave of carbon then submerged
in a gel full of ions when pulled carbon
nanotubes squeeze together decreasing
the electrochemical capacitance and
thereby generating a small current
enough to momentarily light up an LED
previously capacitance change based
mechanical energy harvesters needed an
external voltage to generate electricity
but now this research shows that carbon
nanotubes can produce electricity just
as well without the extra juice the
researchers tested the carbon nanotube
yarns power generating ability in
several situations this shirt has a pair
of these twists rom yarns sewn in when
the wearer breathes in and out a small
amount of electricity is generated which
could be useful data for medical devices
researchers also looked into whether
this tech could harness power from ocean
waves the harvesters worked when placed
in ocean like saltwater and were able to
generate electricity when the wave
motion tugged at the yarn more power can
be generated if the harvesters are
hooked up together with peak power
generation reaching 250 watts per
kilogram
well these proof of concepts don't
generate enough power to light your home
or charge your electric car the
researchers say that due to their
scalable nature these carbon nanotube
yarns may have applications anywhere
reliable kinetic energy is available
[Music]
[Music]